au mémorial de caen c'est l'heure du
briefing du jury avant le grand oral des
lycéens
on leur demande bon évidemment d'avoir
choisi un sujet si peut être original et
vous faire découvrir une pause
moins connu c'est mieux on leur demande
aussi de s'appuyer sur des articles de
loi aux textes internationaux soutenir
leur argumentation
aux côtés des journalistes de la presse
régionale avocats et associations de
défense des droits de l'homme nicolas et
arthur ces deux lycéens un vrai ont
remporté la finale régionale l'an
dernier avec leurs plaidoiries sur les
enfants du bénin pense qu'il était
important pour nous d'être écouté
l'autre entendu et ça peut montrer aussi
que même nous les jeunes on est capable
de s'intéresser à de nobles causes ce
qu'il ya ce qu est importante pour nous
les séances et que pour une fois en tant
que jeunes nous laisse la parole nous
laisse la possibilité de s'exprimer de
pouvoir enfin affirmer quelque chose qui
nous tient à coeur
tout en le défendant devant des
personnes qui vont avoir un impact
beaucoup plus important sinon je viens
ici vers vous aujourd'hui pour dénoncer
une cause qui m'est chère d'art est un
ancien prisonnier politique du vietnam
la torture au vietnam le danger des
puces électroniques
les écoliers sous pression en corée du
sud ou encore la répression en syrie
voilà quelques-uns des thèmes choisis
ils étaient des dizaines bilan de leurs
bottes militaires des grands massés au
sol voilà pour votre liberté criard t-il
voilà pour vos martyrs chacun des dix
candidats ou duos de candidats retenus à
environ huit minutes pour convaincre la
forme le fond les motions
tout est ensuite passé au crible lors
des délibérations
il y avait une bonne diversité des
sujets j'étais assez intéressant le long
mot génie tu n' était pas là entre tous
les candidats
moi j'avais trop a qui sont vraiment
sortis
c'est finalement inès et solène du lycée
victor hugo de caen avec leurs
plaidoiries sur le régime de bachar al
assad qui représenteront la normandie le
27 janvier prochain
vacallo